Hey traders, it's Mike from OrderFlows
here. I'm excited to introduce you to
the OrderFlow Reader AI. Now, the
OrderFlow Reader AI is not a charting
platform. It's not an indicator. It's an
AI-powered order flow analysis tool that
reads your chart, explains what it sees,
and teaches you why it matters. It's the
first tool of its kind. So, all you got
to do is you just upload a foot any
footprint chart. The AI reads it bar by
bar and gives you a complete structured
order flow analysis, then teaches you
why it matters. So, how it works, it's
three simple steps. You take a
screenshot and you upload it, right? You
take a screenshot of any footprint
chart, whether it's NinjaTrader, Sierra
Chart,
uh
other platform you upload it into
OrderFlow Reader AI, and then you're
going to get your analysis, right? It's
going to read every bar. You're going to
get six
layer analysis plus lessons plus a final
verdict, and you can even do it with
trades that you have taken to, uh you
know, get an analysis of the trades that
you took. Then you can export it, right?
You can export to PDF and study the
lessons, uh you know, you're going to be
able to pick up on the order flow that
you miss, and you're going to be able to
build a library based off of the way
that you trade, based off of your chart,
based off of, you know, whatever
indicators you're using. You know, then
you could just go ahead, upload your
next chart. The more charts you run, the
sharper your reads in the order flow
becomes because you're going to be
analyzing the trades that you took. So,
you know, the problem that many traders
have is they see a signal or they see an
order flow nuance, they take the trade,
they get stopped out. Then you ask,
"What did I miss?" You know, you're
reading fragments, right? You're reading
just one bar or maybe one signal. You
got no context. More importantly, you
don't have any trade autopsy. What that
means is you're not looking afterwards
and uh picking up the nuances because,
you know, you're kind of upset. You just
had a a losing trade cuz you got stopped
out. Um you know, maybe you've taken
some courses and but it's not your
chart. You know, what that means is, you
know, you you can take a course on
reading order flow
and it's based around E-minis, but, you
know, maybe you're trading a different
market. Maybe you're trading bonds,
right? So, it's hard sometimes for you
to transfer what you've learned in a
course to the market that you're
trading. You know, what OrderFlow AI
does is it's analyzing your chart,
charts that you have taken trades off of
or charts of markets that you are
watching and explains the order flow to
you.
So, what you're going to get on every
chart you're going to get a current bar
bias, right? Who's in control and why?
You're going to get bar-to-bar
comparison. You're going to see how the
narrative in the order flow shifts.
You're going to get bullish and bearish
zones explained to you, you know, supply
and demand map from the order flow. Um
you're going to look at the current bar
versus those zones, you know, are you
trading with or against the order flow?
You're going to get market context, the
train trend, the range, the reversals,
the breakouts. Then you get a final
verdict, right? You're going to get a
clear stance. You know, you can see all
the evidence that um comes from the
chart.
Now, what makes OrderFlow AI so unique,
so special in my mind, is that it has a
lessons feature. So, you know, it's not
just giving you an analysis of the
chart, but it actually has specific
lessons based off of your chart, you
know, what the AI saw in the order flow,
why it matters for buyer seller
behavior, what to watch for on future
charts. Think of it, every chart you
upload is like a mini education session,
but more importantly, it's built around
the markets that you are trading on your
chart type.
A special feature that we've added into
it is a PDF export. So, you know, one
click, you can save the entire analysis,
all the layers of analysis plus the
lessons as a printable document. So,
you're going to be able to build your
own personal library from your own
trades. You know, imagine if you upload
50 charts, you're going to get a custom
order flow textbook based off of what
you are trading. How else are you going
to learn from your trades if you don't
analyze them? And the beauty is, now AI
is analyzing it, but more importantly,
the AI is trained from me, from, you
know, a professional order flow trader.
So, who's this for? You know, people may
say, "You know, I'm a beginner, do I
really need this?" Or "I'm an expert, I
don't really need this." Well,
if you're a beginner, it's going to
collapse the experience gap. You're
going to see how an institutional read
is performed on charts you're actually
looking at. Build your fluency in order
flow in weeks.
If you're an intermediate trader, you're
going to find holes in your process,
discover the order flow you missed, you
know, the shifts you overlooked. The
real value is in what you're not seeing
yet. If you're an advanced trader,
you're going to have accountability and
documentation. You'll have eagle-free
second opinion on every trade. You'll
have automated trade journaling, build a
library
you always meant to.
You know, when I was learning order
flow, I screenshotted everything
and studied those charts over and over.
I spent years doing that. Most people
don't have years, so I built the
OrderFlow Reader AI. It does everything
I did manually and more in seconds. I
spent a lot of time finding the best AI
model for this. I tested them all. Most
failed. Then I trained the one that
worked with my 20 years of institutional
trading experience. I'll be honest, this
is the tool I wish existed when I was
learning.
Now, the more charts you run, the better
you're going to get as a trader, right?
It's going to be your charts plus AI
analysis um plus the lessons that it
gives you. Um you can print it out to a
PDF library and you're going to get
faster pattern recognition. So, what's
that mean is it's going to help you to
learn spots easily based on your charts.
It's going to reveal your blind spots.
You'll find what you consistently miss
in the order flow.
You're going to be able to process
discipline. What that means is, you
know, it's going to give you the market
bias, the zones, the context, and the
verdicts. And remember, confidence
compounds. You're going to be able to
trust your reads starting, you know,
after about 30 trades that you run
through here. Now, again, you know,
there's no limit to the amount of trades
or charts you can run through, but as
you run more and more and study what the
analysis says, you're just going to
become a better trader overall. So, if
you want to see what it looks like,
let's just take a quick look here. It's
really simple, right? You just load up
you just go to the OrderFlow Reader app
and you just drag your footprint chart
right here.
Um let's see if we got one.
Uh what's a good one here? I'll just
choose this chart right here.
Okay, and so it's there. Let's click
analyze. Simple. And you can see it's
doing the analysis. It's reading the
order flow structure, analyzing delta
and imbalances, evaluating bar-to-bar
context. It's forming its verdict. Now,
you know, there is with uh a footprint
chart you don't want your chart too
scrunched up cuz it's going to be hard
for AI to read the number. You know,
kind of spread out your chart so it's
easy to read. You know, just as as you
would as a trader when you're looking at
the chart, right? You're not going to
have a scrunched up footprint. Now,
again, you know, it's doing its analysis
on the background. So, you know, it
takes a little bit of time, but you
know, it's generally pretty quick
because again, it's it's going through
this whole step-by-step analysis, right?
And it's reading the order flow based
off of what it's been taught. Now, the
beauty is, you know, this is an
ever-evolving
uh tool because we're constantly feeding
it new things to look at in the order
flow, right? Imagine it. It's just like
having um you know, me sitting right you
know, taking a look at your chart. Like
imagine you send me a chart and I
analyze it for you. This is what it's
going to tell you. It's going to tell
you, you know, the current bar
confidence is high. You know, it's
bearish. It gives the explanation,
bar-to-bar
uh comparison. It's telling you what the
market is expecting based off the order
flow. Now, it's going to give you, you
know, the chart map, bullish and bearish
zones. Um you know, it's going to talk
about the order flow, why it's
bullish in certain areas or why it's
bearish in certain areas. Current bar
position, you know, how the current bar
is trading to the context of the market.
There's the market context. Going to
give you a sort of the final verdict,
right? The bearish is strong. It's
expecting the market to maybe go a
little bit lower.
Now, here's where strength is. Learn
from this chart, right? Again, cuz why
is this important? It's because it's
your market, right? You could take
courses, you could watch videos on
YouTube where someone's explaining
something in the order flow, but unless
it's in a market that you're trading, is
it really going to make sense to you?
Maybe, maybe not. It might take you a
while to understand, but now the
analysis is based off of the chart that
you upload. So, then it's giving you
lessons
what it finds important on that chart so
that you can start to look at that. And
as you see in certain markets, there are
certain nuances in the order flow that
really stand out. Now, if you want to
save this, all you do is you click this
button, export PDF, and then it will
create a PDF file that you can download.
Okay?
So, as you can see, you know, this is a
very powerful tool.
And
I'll be honest, you know, this is brand
new. We we haven't launched it out to
the general trading public, but, you
know, as a follower of OrderFlow, I want
you guys to get a special deal, right? I
want you to be able to get lifetime
access instead of paying the monthly
subscription fee that it will be. When
it goes mainstream, it's going to be $59
a month. It's going to be a recurring
charge, you know, so for a course of a
year, you're going to pay over $700.
But right now, the opportunity is to get
in
at the launch, at the ground floor for a
one-time payment. That's it. You're
done. All future updates are included.
And we plan on updating this weekly,
right? With new
order flow nuances, everything, building
out the library. Now, the library's
already very robust, but there's always
little certain things and again,
different markets have different
nuances. And, you know, again, it's AI,
so again, it's still a work in progress.
But if you get in now, you know, the
people who get in now will never pay a
monthly fee. After
we close down this lifetime access deal,
if you want to get in, again, it's going
to cost you $59 a month.
Your lifetime license includes all the
AI-powered order flow analysis on any
footprint chart, right? And again, you
know, we're constantly adding in new
features. You're going to see the
bullish and bearish zones mapped from
the order flow raw data. You're going to
get the bar-to-bar comparison showing
how the narrative shifts. Current bar
analyzed to relative key zones, you
know, market context, you know, plus a
clear final verdict. The lessons
feature, learn why from every chart you
upload. PDF export, build your own
personal trading library. You know, like
I said, I always recommend traders when
I when I work with them, they ask me,
you know, how can they improve in order
flows? I print up your chart, mark it
up, save it. This does that work for
you.
And more importantly, this is trained by
me, right? I'm a
have over 20 years of institutional
order flow trading experience, you know,
I worked at JP Morgan, worked at
Commerzbank, Cargill, EDF Man, Dean
Witter, um you know, I started on the
CME floor.
All future updates and improvements are
included forever.
Most importantly, no monthly fees, no
annual renewal. Let's say one payment,
you're done, you're locked in.
So, all you got to do, again, you just
upload your chart, you get the read,
start seeing what you've been missing.
Lifetime access is only $149 for
one-time payment. This is the
ground-floor pricing.
All future updates, no monthly fees,
one-time payments. All right, again, you
know, ask yourself, how many more trades
are you going to take without analyzing
what the order flow is actually telling
you? Think of it like this, right? We
all know what ChatGPT is. This is not
ChatGPT. This is
something beyond ChatGPT. You know,
ChatGPT can read a document, understand
it, and explain to you
in plain language, right? But
Order Flow Reader AI does the same thing
with your footprint chart. You upload
it, the AI reads it, and it gives you a
complete breakdown of what the order
flow is saying, and then teaches you why
it matters, right? And that's important
because
as a trader, you want to keep learning,
right? You want to keep expanding your
knowledge of order flow analysis, of
what the market is doing. And the Order
Flow Reader AI is that tool that's going
to get you to that next level much, much
faster than trying to figure it on your
own,
watching YouTube videos, reading um
PDFs, etc., right? Th- This really will
level you up in a much faster
time frame than trying to figure
everything out on your own. So, get in
now, and I'll see you guys on the
inside.